joining me now is arkansas senator tom
cotton senator i think the most um
shocking thing
of all the shocking things that we've
seen is that after all this destruction
that the democrats have created left in
their wake
the left is just doubling down on the
same policies they don't make any change
whatsoever
yeah laura i think the only thing
they've changed their tune on is now
they seem to pretend that they believed
all along school closures were bad and
that school closures have had negative
impacts on kids but as you lay down to
near monologue very well you and i and
others in the spring of 2020 were saying
we had to get our schools open again and
that's exactly what we did in states
like arkansas in the fall of 2020 we had
kids in classes five days a week a lot
of other states did as well but all
those democratic-run states and school
districts kept their schools closed and
did a great job of cataloging
all of the misery and pain that we've
inflicted on our children they've fallen
behind academically
emotionally and socially many of them
are stunted in their development and all
that idle time has led to a surge in
juvenile delinquency and crime but as
you say what does the body
administration done beside school
closures they just doubled down on all
these policies when parents
when the one silver lining of these
closures saw what their kids were being
indoctrinated with and began to stand up
at school boards or run for school
boards merrick garland sick the feds on
them joe biden is waging war on charter
schools they're using title ix to try to
ruin women's sports and force kids to
learn more about what pronouns to use
rather than how to get a subject and a
verb to agree with each other and as you
say parents are fed up with this across
the country and parents are going to
reject the democrats this fall because
they have not forgotten what these
democrats have done to our children for
the last two years yeah hurting our
economy is bad enough hurting our kids
we won't tolerate that and the the
amazing thing as well senator is that
failure
gets rewarded in liberal land because
gavin newsom is headed to washington
to accept an award in recognition of
california's transformative improvements
to education now just a note on the
citation of the award it's for his
explicit attention to whole child
supports and services now california
offered children the least in-person
school senator of any state
in the country this is insulting yeah
yeah that that's a farce and tragically
california public schools have been
failing their kids since long before
this pandemic the school closures only
accelerated the academic losses and the
crime we see among our children
again that's why i and you and so many
other conservatives two years ago were
advocating to keep our kids in schools
and we're standing up in the fight
against things like the 1619 project and
critical race theory when a lot of
republicans didn't want to touch those
issues that's what we've been doing the
last two years and i promise you
when we win the majorities back this
fall that's what we're going to start
doing in january we're going to put the
brakes on this radical democratic agenda
and start focusing on teaching our kids
not just how to get the skills they need
to get a good job in our economy but
also teaching them to love our country
and to be good citizens as well and and
speaking of that senator maisie hirono
from hawaii
made a interesting to put it kindly
comment about the constitution on
capitol hill today
with the attitude or the approach of
originalism they have the justices who
take that approach go all the way back
to
our founding fathers and pretend that
they know what our founding fathers
meant
when they drafted the constitution
i use the word pretent because who the
heck was should what would know
what our founding fathers meant
well why should why should kids have any
respect for our founding documents if
she basically is just blowing it all off
like it doesn't matter
yeah that's another head scratcher from
maisie hirono gosh how could you
possibly understand laura what our
founding fathers
thought the constitution the declaration
meant
maybe it's that james madison and
alexander hamilton wrote 85 different
newspaper columns now collected in
something called the federalist papers
or that madison and jefferson and adams
in washington wrote letters and speeches
and ordinances and resolutions that
total up volumes and volumes of what
they believed about america and the
promise that america held for everyone
that's exactly what justices should be
doing and that should also be what
guides us in congress what guides our
legislators across the country is
fulfilling those founding ideals not
simply dismissing them as if they're
somehow unknowable when the founders
literally wrote multi-volume books about
what the constitution means well well
senator you actually think maisie hirono
has poured through the federalist papers
okay then you and i might disagree on
that it's great to see you tonight as
always senator cotton hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else